well thank you yeah thank you so very
much I just want to start by saying I
have never restored any movie I find
that hard to believe I'm working on it
room actually is a little tidbit about
this apparently this film they found the
original negative but it had been cut
into down the middle by Carl Laemmle in
a fit of pique one even got really drunk
and they painstakingly tits stitched
together which was amazing only with
computer technology the Sui actually we
did we reenacted it last night yeah and
I haven't gotten over that was that last
night I think so oh by the way now many
of you have taken like one of these
little items at a concert and you know
going like this right and whatever well
you couldn't do that in nineteen thirty
so this is about the closest thing yeah
II always sort of the state of the art
technology Sam was only you know a
couple years old in color where they
were just fooling around with it and
like woo to we just need two colors
that's all yeah but what you're going to
see but what you're gonna see tonight is
essentially it's it's the MTV of the
1930s I mean this is really a music
video what you're watching tonight which
is really fun you know do you guys know
there's a cartoon in this yeah yeah and
it's a Woody Woodpecker could well dad
wouldn't not quite what he was Walter
Lantz yes ten years before Woody
Woodpecker that crazy no yeah he was he
was like 30 years or 30 years old when
he did this he directed a lot of like
shorts such as hmm you know stuff as you
can see we're obsessed very studied this
but we really are obsessed with jazz
we're obsessed with music and we're
obsessed with movies and I'm also so
happy to be able to say that we are part
of an organization organization that
puts on events like this and and and
chooses to actually protect film and
protect it so we can show my kids who
are here tonight I'm so happy to see
that they're going to see this tonight
and for everyone else so thank you guys
for for doing this
hello you know what in my orchestra
there's a gentleman named Don Williams
and Don is the brother of john williams
who you may know and these are in a few
things a couple things and Don is
amazing Don's an amazing timpani player
is a drummer but his father and John's
father also was a drummer and an
incredible drummer played a lot of big
bands but he also played with Paul
Whiteman as well and i was talking to
Don about that and he said that that you
know all the gang used to come over and
he remembers when he was a real little
kid a lot of his dad's friends used to
come over and just jam in the house but
he needs to tell stories about working
with Paul Whiteman I think that's kind
of kind of fun well it's great too
because Paul Whiteman was born in 1890
and many of the great you know like
Louie Armstrong and so forth they're all
born like 10 years later so he was sort
of before he came up from an earlier era
of music when he was a kid yeah in fact
and Duke Ellington himself called him
the king of jazz as well he said he
earned that title more than anybody so I
mean if you're going to get that kind of
praise that's pretty good yeah